[Captions by Y Translator]
Today, we're going to be taking
a look at how to fill up a balloon
from the outside using
a vacuum cleaner and a bucket,
and then filling
the balloon with a bunch of
things that wouldn't normally
fit inside a balloon.
Normally, when you inflate a balloon,
you're increasing the
pressure inside the balloon,
and not doing anything
to the pressure outside it.
Well today we'll build a device
that lets us do the opposite.
We will decrease the pressure
outside the balloon
while leaving the pressure
inside the balloon the same.
We should get the exact same
effect causing the balloon
to inflate even though the
mouth of the balloon will be
completely wide open.
Here is the basic plan.
The bucket should act as a sort of vacuum
chamber to the outside of the balloon.
When we pull all the air
out of the bucket,
the low pressure should
cause the balloon to expand.
To start off, we're going
to need a large bucket,
a plastic container
with a decently wide mouth,
and we're also going to be
using this plastic ball valve.
If you don't want to use this,
it's not 100% necessary
but I think it should make it easier.
This container is what we're going
to use to attach our balloon
onto the bucket lid.
So the first thing we have to do is
cut the top off of the container
so it can be attached to the bucket.
We now need to attach
this container top onto our bucket.
And to do that, we want to cut a hole
in our bucket the same size
as the neck fit it up through the bucket
lid from the bottom
and then glue it in place
with some hot glue.
There we go.
Our little mouth is now in place so
let's glue it on with our hot glue gun.
In addition to attaching
this piece onto the bucket lid,
we also want to try and make an airtight
seal going all the way around.
If it's not perfect, it should still work.
It just won't work quite as well.
We'll have this hole where the balloon
goes and where we can then
put other things inside of
the balloon while it's inflated.
Next up.
We need to add a spot
that lets us pull all of the air out.
And for that,
we've got this PVC ball valve.
We're just going to drill a hole
the right size for the valve,
and then glue this in place
down at the bottom of the bucket.
Now you can make this work
without adding a valve.
You can cut a hole into the bottom
and hold the vacuum hose up to it.
It will suck the air out
that will inflate the balloon.
But if you want to be able to do anything,
you're going to have
to leave the hose attached to the side
of the bucket with the vacuum running.
Otherwise the pressure will equalize
and the balloon will just shrink again.
With the ball valve glued
in place in the opening in the lid,
we should be able
to start vacuuming this out.
Let's give it a quick try
and just make sure that our air
flow is doing what we want it to.
Oh yeah.
Now what we need to do is stretch this balloon
neck all the way around this opening
that we added into our lid.
At this point, if we attach the vacuum
on to our valve down here at the bottom,
it's going to start pulling air
out of the bucket
and when that happens, there will be low
pressure in the bucket
and normal atmospheric
pressure inside the balloon.
Normally atmospheric pressure is equal
to or less than what's inside a balloon.
If you're not blowing into it, it's equal.
If you are blowing into it, it's less.
But we're going to alter the setup.
So that what's inside the balloon
at atmospheric pressure
is still higher than what's around it.
And that should cause it to inflate.
All right.
See if we can get this to inflate.
Beautiful.
So the vacuum pulled all the air out
and while it was pulling,
I turned the valve and we now have
our balloon inflated inside the bucket
even though the top
of the balloon is wide open.
The mouth of the balloon
is completely open.
Look at this. Weeee.
I can stick my arm down
inside the balloon with no resistance.
Now this is pretty cool
and it's working really well.
However, there is
a modification I want to make.
And this isn't something that you need
to do if you're building one of these.
This is just so we can see it better.
I want to put a window into the side
of this bucket so we can
check out what's going on.
This is an acrylic sheet that
I just melted a little bit
with a heat gun to give it a little bit of curve.
Now we're going to cut a hole
in the side of the bucket
and then we are going to use some very
strong tape to attach this here.
And again this is not
a functional aspect of the build.
This is just so we can watch
what's happening inside the bucket.
We've got our window.
Let's reattach our lid.
Now that we can see what's
going on inside the bucket,
let's try this again.
Look at that.
You can actually see the window
through the balloon.
This balloon when fully inflated,
which it's definitely
not inside the bucket,
it should be almost
three feet in diameter.
So let the air back in
and watch this thing shrink.
And I can stop it
by putting my hand on it.
I can open it all the way
and just shrinks quickly.
Let's blow that back up.
Close the valve again.
One of the interesting things
about blowing a balloon up
like this and of course leaving
the opening open is that you can then
put other things inside the balloon.
Like I could blow up another full-size
balloon inside this balloon.
Or if I wanted, I can
put some other things.
And I'm going to actually try
and create a little design
that will go inside the balloon.
After it's finished, I'll take the neck
of the balloon off of the top
of the bucket, all of the extra air will
rush out of course as the seal
is broken, then I'll remove the
balloon with the stuff inside it,
and then I'll blow the balloon
the rest of the way up.
So we have a big clear
balloon with stuff inside it.
So, let's give this a shot.
Let's start with a bunch
of water balloons.
Just gonna start throwing these in.
These are only held
closed by rubber bands.
Almost always enough
for water but for air,
it can sometimes leak out.
Next up, we've got a shark.
We're gonna try and fit the shark down in.
Now obviously the shark is uh...
well he's not going to fit in like that.
So we're going to have
to squish him a good bit.
But before we do that,
there's another modification
I think we need.
Sharks with frickin' lazers on their heads.
Normally I would have to
do something to modify it.
So I was constantly pushing down
the button but this laser pointer
was really really cheap and I
don't think it was very well made
because it just stays on all the time
as long as there batteries in it.
Not sure if hot glue is what Dr. Evil
had in mind for attaching the lasers
to the sharks heads but it works for us.
Such a happy shark
with a laser on his head.
Fortunately this shark is quite squishy.
Okay.
I think that'll do it.
This thread is attached
to the shark's head,
and we're going to actually leave
that outside of the balloon
because that's we're going
to try and use to suspend
the shark right where we want it.
Now we're going to let
some of the air back in.
That's starting to push the shark out.
Okay instead of that, we're just
going to take our balloon neck
and peel it back up over the mouth here.
So we've now got a shark and
a bunch of compressed balloons
inside a bigger balloon.
We want to blow the bigger balloon back
up and we're going to use a pump to do that
rather than breath because breath
has a lot of moisture in it
and we want it to stay nice
and clear on the inside.
There is our shark with
a fricken' laser on its head
floating around in it's
blue balloon water.
Very cool.
Blowing up a balloon from the outside
and filling it with all sorts of things.
But I did get another idea
while I was filling this up.
You know I used all of
these water balloons
and I just blew them up with air.
I gotta try filling a balloon with water
balloons that are actually full of water.
So yeah, let's try that.
I'm going to end up
with some extra water
just at the bottom of this
balloon but that's okay.
Yeah.
Like I was saying the extra
water that kind of sprays out.
It was definitely surrounding all of them.
So it's like a water balloon full
of smaller water balloons at this point.
Try and pick it up.
Hopefully it doesn't just pop.
There we go.
That worked better than I thought.
I thought a lot of the smaller
balloons would survive.
But I only see like one
maybe two that didn't explode.
So just what I was hoping for.
How to make a giant
water balloon grenade?
Compound water balloon.
I don't know what to call it.
But it was really fun.
Bucket with a valve in a vacuum lets
you inflate a balloon from the outside
by lowering the pressure
around the balloon, the atmospheric
pressure inside the balloon
is enough to push it open.
Very cool stuff.
Guys, thanks for watching.
We've got more for you to see though.
That box at the top will take
you directly to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The box at the bottom will show
you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching now.
And this bomb in the middle is
how you subscribe to the channel.
So you never miss out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see the next one.
Talk to you then.